hallo herzlich willkommen zufällig
torten will heute gibt es wieder eine
advents pöschl von mir und weiß ich
jetzt schon der dritte teil also
weihnachten steht kurz bevor und schaut
euch mal an wer heute bei mir was
bestellt hat die hallo ich bin's die
analyse
ich habe letztens habe ich die matthias
reim getroffen kündete matthias reim der
think verdammt ich lieb dich und so habe
ich getroffen habe ich ganz aufgegeben
habe ich gerufen
matthias matthias reim der ebenfalls
standard hat mir dafür gedicht
geschrieben
jetzt hat der macd kurz vor die große
weihnachtsshow mache ich mich im
rezeptbuch schlau damit mein mann denn
das wäre bitter nicht sagen kann ach das
schon wieder demontiert
das roastbeef war zu lustig und das
fleisch zu rosé ich bekam schenkel um
die ohren und contra beim re er wohl
statt lammbraten lieber lambada am ende
und es hat ihm was gefehlt zwischen
meinl ende wie manche konnten es
etikette einen hol dich nicht der war
mir zu teuer soll 20 liter sprit und es
sitzen idiot am steuer ist das so
und beim gänsekeule habe ich dann
gefoult
es wird doch schon genug gänse und
hühner gekeult ich hab doch hühnerbrust
für die ttg ohne pralle wenn hühner
meine brüste brust hätte würde sie nach
vorne war
ich habe ihn k o schlag mit der dresdner
stunde und als ersatz bestelle ich mehr
bei sally achtung getrennt sich bizkit
rolle schöne weihnachten bleibt ist
danke dir analyse für deine bestellung
und für dich habe ich mir was ganz
besonderes ausgedacht ich werde heute
nämlich eine biskuitrolle mit muster
machen
wer dieses muster mitmachen möchte ganz
auch weglassen und einfach die
weihnachtliche biskuitrolle backen
aber ich zeige jetzt einfach mal wie man
das muster macht und was ihr dafür als
zutaten benötigt für die muster creme
braucht ihr ein eiweiß das eigene
passiert davon übrig habt das bemüht
sich einfach später für den biskuit teig
ihr braucht 40 gramm mehl 30 gramm öl
und 30 gramm zucker und ich bin uns
jetzt hier noch etwas speise farbe und
zwar einmal in rot und einmal hellgrün
und tannengrün das werde ich etwas
zusammen mischen und jetzt gebt ihr
einfach die zutaten in den mix topf
könnte aber auch ganz gut mit
schneebesen verrühren
ganz einfach
das ist ihm auch schon jetzt fühle ich
mir das hier in zwei verschiedene teller
weil ich eben ein bisschen grünen ein
bisschen brot haben möchte ihr könnt den
teig aber auch einfach hängen lassen
oder mit karo einfärben
je nachdem wie euer tag der machen wird
also der bis jetzt gebe ich hier mit
einem sauberen löffel etwas rot mit rein
diese zwei farben fühle ich mich in
meine spritzbeutel ich habe jetzt hier
einmal die tülle mit einem millimeter
durchmesser und einmal die thuner mit 2
mm durchmesser und ich nehme die mit
zwei millimetern durchmesser für rot und
die mit dem kleinen durchmesser folge
und hier habe ich mir jetzt auf
backpapier ein kleines muster gezeichnet
ich habe mich komplett fertig gezeichnet
ich habe hier ein paar tannenbäume und
kreise dass ich das was ich jetzt hier
so drauf machen möchte und wichtig ist
dann sieht es dann um dreht also das
jetzt nicht auf diese bleistiftzeichnung
mal sondern dass sie auf die rückseite
malt
und dann müsste es nicht und können dann
schon vor packen
so siehts dann bei mir nach dem backen
aus also es hat noch richtig schön seine
farbe behalten und es soll ja einfach
nur ganz kurz an stoffen
ich hatte auch schon so gemacht dass ich
den tag nicht vor gebacken sondern
einige frauen habe aber dann ist es
einfach schon passiert dass der taipan
verlaufen ist deswegen finde ich die
variante mit dem vorbeugen besser und
hat jetzt deswegen auch so gemacht da
müssen wir darauf achten dass ihr das
eben nicht so dunkel back damit die
farbe schon erhalten bleibt und im
nächsten schritt zeige ich euch jetzt
mal jemand den biss geteilt herstellt
und über nie verarbeitet für den biskuit
teig braucht ihr drei eier dann gehe ich
da auch noch das icap dazu was ich
vorhin übrig hatte ihr braucht 80 gramm
zucker 50 g speisestärke 50 gramm mehl
und 20 gramm kakaopulver und halben
teelöffel backpulver und ich habe jetzt
hier noch einen halben teelöffel
lebkuchengewürz also ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen zimt kardamom nelken und an
ließ den teig verrührt einfach in der
schüssel in der ich eben den muster teig
verrührt habe nehme dazu die schneebesen
und dann spielen wir erst die eier mit
dem zucker
dann gebt ihr die trockenen zutaten
einfach in den teig die möchte ich jetzt
aber vorher noch sieben damit ich keine
klümpchen habe damit es einmal
untergehoben
und jetzt habe ich hier schon mal meinen
ba grant außenrum gegeben
ich mag nämlich die biskuitrolle ganz
gern über grant und jetzt gebt ihr ganz
vorsichtig den teig oben drauf wie eine
decke das ganz ganz vorsichtig
verstreichen
und so wie der teig jetzt bei 175 grad
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten gebacken
er darf auf keinen fall zu dunklen
werden so sieht datei jetzt bei mir aus
die stäbchen probe habe ich gemacht
er ist durch ich hätte noch ein bisschen
glatt streichen könne aber das macht
nichts dann wenn er noch ganz heiß war
content fans mit mir geradezu eine folie
um das ganze mal umzudrehen und
kontaktierten sie könnte es auch leicht
feuchten
jetzt nehme ich mir ein geschirrtuch und
gibt es darüber weil jetzt muss man
nochmal umdrehen damit eben dann später
das muster außen ist und jetzt rolle ich
das ganze ein
beim display es ist ganz wichtig dass
ihr dem ich zu dunkel backt das heißt
bei mir waren etwa zehn minuten dann
waren durch ich habe die stäbchen probe
gemacht ich habe also den samstag
genommen habe den in den teig
eingestochen und beim herausziehen täter
nichts mehr dran daran könnt ihr das
erkennen und die biskuitrolle muster auf
sofort raus weise ansonsten zu trocken
wird und euch dann die rolle später beim
aufrollen bricht ich werde jetzt die
rolle abkühlen lassen und weil ihnen
derzeit schon mal die creme vorbereiten
da habe ich mir überlegt dass ich meine
cappuccino creme macht einfach mal was
anderes und zwar möchte ich diese
cappuccino creme noch ein bisschen
verfeinern mit etwas mehl und kompott
den stelle ich auch gleich her und was
ihr dazu an zutaten benötigt es zeigt
ihr euch jetzt für die creme braucht er
300 gramm magerquark 300 gramm sahne 75
gramm puderzucker 75 gramm cappuccino
pulver 1 esslöffel kakao und ich habe
hier noch etwas an apparate sind sechs
teelöffel drei davon brauche ich für den
quark und drei davon für die samen
zuerst kümmere ich mich jetzt um die
sahne und schlag dich schreiben und wenn
sie etwas angeschlagen ist gebe ich etwa
drei teelöffel von diesem fall apart mit
dazu
die stein ist stelle ich in den
kühlschrank dann gebt ihr die restlichen
zutaten einfach nochmal in die
rührschüssel
und stellt einen verrührt bis alles
schön vermerkt ist
es müsste hier noch die sahne unterheben
und die creme stelle ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank wie sie etwas fester
geworden ist
das innen komplett könnt ihr auch schon
etwas früher herstellen also auch schon
bevor er den teig back weil nämlich
ihren kompott ganz kalt sein muss ich
habe dafür einfach eine wende genommen
ein bisschen apfelsaft und etwa einen
teelöffel stärke und werde ich jetzt im
schnelldurchlauf einmal zeigen wie ich
es halt gestellt habe
zeig ich euch mal wie ich die rolle
fülle und zwar wollt ihr das ganz
langsam auf da musst du aufpassen damit
euch die rolle eben jetzt nicht bricht
und dann kommt da die creme obendrauf
und da bietet nicht bis ganz zum rand
streichen weil es da nämlich später
ausläuft und hier gebe jetzt gerade so
ein bisschen was von der birne mit rein
da aufpassen ohne die zimtstangen
einfach so ein bisschen für den
geschmack jetzt wird es ganz ganz
vorsichtig aufgerollt
jetzt klappt ich das zu und es leuchtet
vielleicht raus das macht aber nix und
gibt es so in den kühlschrank damit die
creme ist richtig schön fest werden
dieses rezept gefällt euch in ihr
probiert es mal auf ihr könnt ihr eure
natürlich in jeder geschmacksrichtung
machen in der sie euch gefällt ich habe
es schon zwei mal gemacht ich kann euch
im nächsten schritt gleich mal die zwei
videos auch verlieren können
ich wünsche euch jetzt auf jeden fall
noch einen schönen dritten advent
wünsche ich ein schönes wochenende
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr mit euren
freunden teilen meine bewertungen gibt
oder einen kommentar last und alle infos
könnt ihr natürlich auch www.estos.de
nachlesen oder sehen wird vom nächsten
mal wieder
die
die l
sieglos